i
adore you both so much
it felt so consistently phenomenal
ariana grande gets emotional on the
voice after she was faced with some
tough decisions about who gets to
continue on to the knockout rounds and
who has to go home on monday's first
night of the season 21 battle rounds ari
and her celeb advisor kristin chenoweth
felt all the feels during rehearsals i
chose kristin chenoweth as my battle
advisor i love her so much she is one of
my favorite human beings on the planet
but i just felt like from a vocal
techniques standpoint she's so
incredibly brilliant and
you know
she's a technician of a vocalist she's
brilliant in that way the two got
emotional over contestants katie ray and
bella dinopoly and their dueling
performances of no more tears enough is
enough by barbara streisand and donna
summer it's raining it's boring
this song means a lot to me my mom and i
would sing it together in the car all
the time but those emotional rehearsals
were nothing compared to the performance
on the main stage
[Music]
after katie and bella wowed the coaches
with their dynamic battle duet featuring
proud coach ari singing along it was
time to make a choice blake shelton said
he was leaning towards bella while john
legend and kelly clarkson both applauded
katie's unique darker tone but for ari
the decision was harder than she could
have anticipated i
a you both so much
it felt so consistently phenomenal
there's nothing that either of you can't
sing and i feel so privileged to work
with you and have spent this time with
you both and i'm just so proud of you
both and thankful to work with you the
whole thing made kelly tear up too i
literally talked to my therapist about
this i was like
but ultimately ari picked katie as the
winner of the battle i think it was just
a matter of emotion every time katie
opened her mouth i got goosebumps oh and
plot twist she hit her save button to
keep bella on her team too i was able to
save my bellatonopoly my italian sista
i think she's an incredible vocalist i
think she's such a bright light but ari
isn't the only softie in the bunch blake
made an uncharacteristically sweet
gesture when he offered the first time
coach a box of tissues backstage before
she had to make her first tough cuts of
the season after this season you won't
ever need these again you'll get it my
heart does dissolve
you'll become callous like the like this
is so sweet that's a nice gesture look
at this guy there's a heart in there
look i'm married now i'm gonna solve it
i was only trying to impress gwen of
course blake married former voice coach
gwen stefani back in july i don't i
can't remember
i don't want to remember what i was like
before
gwen actually if that answers your
question look how nice i am now but all
that mushy stuff kind of goes out the
window when the coaches remember they're
here to win and now that ariana is on
the panel well the pressure is
definitely on she's a threat she is
hugely talented hugely successful and
has legions and legions of fans that
know how to use the internet and vote
everything he just said
so we all knew it coming in i was
prepared i came within battle armor
i'm prepared to be turned down just
being new there's so much to learn but i
feel like i just get to learn watching
them and it's been amazing
[Music]
you